تتجه الانظار في اكبر مدن المغرب لمواجهه
الحاسمه مع فرنسا
صوت يحلو في كازابلانكا فوق زئير الاسود
الاطلس في المونديال بدانه زائر غير مخيف
وانما يثير الدهشه والبهجه في جميع فئات
المجتمع البيضاوي
سعيد العمراني تنحدر من عائله
ارستقراطيه اخصائيه تجاره
في المدينه
جميع شرائح المجتمع المغربي فرحانين بعد
الفوز ديال المنتخب ديالنا وكنتمنى لهم
التوفيق ومستعدين سدوا الكلينيك ديالنا
باش باش نساندهم وندعموهم وفرحانين بيهم
بزاف والله يكمل عليهم بالخير هذا المنتخب
فوتنا العرب عونك تعاونوا معنا شجعونا
بشرى الضو ناشطه المعروفه على وسائل
التواصل في الدار البيضاء وهي تواصل
حملتها لموازره المنتخب المغربي حتى
العوده بالكاس كما تقول
نهار الثلاثاء
ان شاء الله ههه
ههه الطول اسود ويلتهم ومعاهم المغاربه
وان شاء الله الى
[موسيقى]
وفيما ينتشر ارتياح واسع وترتسم ابتسامات
على الوجوه في مدينه مازالت تعيش حلا وقع
التاهل التاريخي على حسابي اسبانيا
والبرتغال يامل سكان الدار البيضاء ان
تكتمل الفرحه بهزيمه فرنسا خالد جنود
العربيه دار البيضاء